I love speed I love the rush I mean I
skydive I race cars I serve I snowboard
I do all that stuff but I think what's
good about this movie is I think it
shows the downside I think it shows that
there's a risk Wow ominous works late
Paul Walker back in 2000 promoting The
Fast and the Furious 13 years before his
tragic car crash now tomorrow a new
documentary I am Paul Walker celebrates
Paul's life with never-before-seen
footage and interviews with those who
knew him best
it didn't matter like when he didn't
have anything at all and then when he
had everything like nothing about him
changed
Paul's Need for Speed was pretty ironic
considering what he told us on our first
fast and furious set visit back in 2000
we went to this racing school in Vegas I
learned just how little I really knew
about driving Paul caught on fast but
sadly it was also a high-speed crash
that killed him nearly five years ago if
you loved him the way we did you would
say well why him and not us
in the new paramount Network documentary
friends and family really open up about
Paul
we had a Motorhome but the boys always
popped up their tents and I would get
the kids and we would go out to the tide
pool Paul actually confirmed his love of
the great outdoors during his last
interview with us a few months before he
died I grew up hunting and fishing and
I've always been in archery
my family I was just stuff we did like
that's just the way it was whenever I go
surfing whenever I go fishing I think of
him 100% lookalike brothers Caleb and
Cody filled in for Paul in some Furious
7 scenes even recreating Paul's tattoo
of daughter meadow yet an emotional
thing about it but he loved that tattoo
it was really weird having to rock that
thing your daughter might think you're
like the coolest dad in the whole wide
world
she thinks I'm a dork she does the dream
is to have it all who says you can't
have your cake and eat it too
you only live one time I want to get it
on I am Paul Walker ears tomorrow on
paramount network
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]